look here now gay men you'll never be
the woman that we are no matter how
gates Wendy Williams is in the hot seat
once again this time it's for comments
she made about gay men on Thursday's
episode of her show we've got a lot to
talk about during hot topics Wendy
polled the audience to see who plans on
celebrating Valentine's Day she had this
to say when men started clapping well
first of all if you're a man and you're
clapping you're not even a part of this
okay all right you don't even understand
the rules of the day it's women going
out and getting saucy and then going
back home yeah you're not a part I don't
care if you're gay you don't get
immensely every 28 days and her comments
well they didn't stop there you can do a
lot that we do but I get offended by the
idea that we go through something you
will never go through and stop wearing
our skirts and our heels
just saying girls what do we have for
ourselves
although the audience applauded many
viewers at home ran to social media to
criticize the talk show hosts comments
once what are users saying quote Wendy
Williams let the gays wear their skirts
and heels they are the reason you look
good when you step out on your stage
another saying quote a Twitty Williams
Willie
what sort of ignorance is coming out of
your mouth regarding gay men wanting to
be women really Wendy look
we agree to disagree although Wendy's
comments were met with a lot of backlash
some people online agreed with her this
fan tweeted at Wendy Williams thank you
for saying what we as women want to
scream every day hashtag gay men hash
tag let us have something later on in
the show Wendy made it very clear that
she stands by everything she says on the
show saying quote I say it and I mean it
[Music]